excelsior so given that the passing of
Stanley is not even like current news
anymore I really should have done this
before but it didn't occur to me for a
little bit and then I had to find a way
to squeeze it in so I'm gonna count down
my pick for the top ten Stan Lee cameos
in films no I have no need to preamble
this let's get right into it so number
ten we're gonna go with Captain America
Civil War he comes in towards the very
end delivering a package for Tony Stark
or as he says Tony stank is it cheesy
yes cheesy but something about Stan
saying it the way that he does yeah it
makes me smile and it's a moment of
levity that simple we're kind of needed
at the end so thank you for that one
Stan next up number nine we will go to
the first Avengers film again coming in
towards the end of the film where we
have the montage of clips from various
you know people being interviewed on the
news of their thoughts about the
Avengers and and Stan is an old guy
playing chess in Central Park and he's
just sort of looking over his shoulder
and he goes superheroes in New York give
me a break
which of course aside from being like
feeling like a very New York kind of
answer and being adorable as Stan tended
to be there's the fact that it is kind
of a joke in the Marvel Universe the
fact that every single heroes in New
York so for the guy who basically
created the world in which that is the
case to be like that's ridiculous yeah
that's kind of fun just a little meta
number eight Deadpool it's just kind of
fun to see Stan cut loose and be the DJ
at a strip club like that like that's it
I've got no more insight
Juan's depth s just fun number seven
Captain America the First Avenger where
Stan plays a general in World War two
expecting to see Captain America and he
ends up whispering doesn't mean it's
home I thought he'd be taller and it's
aside from being kind of a funny note
and it's also you know a little bit of
nod to Stan's actual service in the
military and that's something that it
also gets touched on some of his other
came in as including some more that are
in fact on this list number six
fittingly enough big hero six now if you
didn't stick around for the post-credits
of this one you missed his actual proper
cameo or the full cameo so been a little
while since this one came out and like
why is Disney working on frozen 2 and
they made wreck-it Ralph to what like
when there wasn't a big hero 6 to like
that's the one that actually lent itself
to see anyways
so initially what we get is that one of
the characters Fred who is the guy with
the least brains but the most enthusiasm
and also apparently a really rich father
we see a portrait on a wall of his
father who is very clearly Stanley and
that's it for the movie proper but then
in the post-credits sequence apparently
Fred stumbles across a hidden room and
hints that his dad was some kind of hero
in his own right and then Stanley shows
up for his obligatory cameo and says and
tells him we've got a lot of stuff to
talk about and it's just cool and fun
and sweet and that's sort of like that's
the epitome of the Stan Lee cameo they
were sweet they they so rarely felt
self-indulgent they just felt sweet so
moving on number 5 guardians of the
galaxy vol 2 this one it maybe goes on
for a little longer than it should
especially in the the post-credits bit
but there was something really cool
about this cameo basically confirming
the fan theory so withstand showing up
over and over and over and over again
throughout the MCU it because it become
adopted fan theory that he was in some
ways tied to the Watchers which is a
conceit from the Marvel Universe of
these beings who observe but do not
interfere or intervene in events and the
thing I think some people actually did
have the theory that he was uatu the
watcher which in this cameo it's clear
that he's not but he is relaying
information to them so they did tie
stand to the Watchers which is it's the
kind of thing where normally I would
think look you don't need to explain a
series of cameos there's no need to do
that but it's done in a way that is fun
and quick and just for the people who
catch it and get what's going on it just
all that you know everything fits
together in a way that doesn't feel true
to me oh yeah number four Avengers age
of Ultron again we have an
acknowledgment of Stan's service in the
military which is something I always
kind of appreciate seeing but also I
love the idea of him trying to drink a
Norse God under the table and losing
like I almost kind of wish he gonna go
to held his own up against them but
there's something nice about him sort of
being led away of sort of all slumped
over drunk
which that's the only time he said it in
any of his cameos but yeah that was
again it was sweet it was nice it was
good not to his own history was good
stuff here we go top three and here's a
surprise for you and hain't even a
Marvel movie Teen Titans go so if he
didn't see Teen Titans go he shuts up
Teen Titans go to the movies
the the thrust of that film is that
Robin wants a superhero movie made well
specifically about him but about the
Teen Titans because you're not a real
hero until you've had a movie made about
you so they go to a movie studio and
they see all these here are all these DC
heroes who are you know there they have
their movies made and in the background
sort of like peeking in from the sides
is Stan Lee until he rushes up and
wrestles control of the camera and goes
hey everybody it's Stan Lee here for my
subtle cameo and it isn't that in fact
voiced by Stan Lee and somebody whispers
to him this is a DC movie I gotta get
out of here and he then shows up later
again towards the end of the film again
like just getting in the way being like
I don't care if it's not a Marvel movie
I love cameos and I mean I like Teen
Titans go to the movies anyways but that
just real I love that they got him for
that it was just so funny so two more to
go both of which are tied to I think
Stan's greatest creation and that's
spider-man so first we have the amazing
spider-man which not a particularly blur
particular blättler speak man speak not
a particularly good spider-man film it's
okay but I really do love his cameo in
it and I think what I love about it is
allows him to command the screen
visually but not feel like he's
intruding on the story because is cameos
that they're worse can feel like an
intrusion and they can kind of pull you
out of it
and none of those instances are on this
list obviously I think a really good
example of that would be his cameo in
the first Fantastic Four movie yeah but
here what is going on is he is a
librarian at the school
and he's just sorting books with
headphones on and it's it's a fairly
stock moment where somebody isn't aware
of all the chaos going on behind them
because they have headphones on because
yes because that's how headphones work
even noise canceling right but anyway
it's a trope but there's something about
him having the music and sort of mmm as
he's dealing with books while the lizard
and Spidey beat the ever-loving crap out
of each other behind him and the moment
that I really loved was this table goes
flying towards Stan and it's about to
hit him and Spidey get gets a web on it
and brings it back pretty sure he hit
the lizard with it when he did that I
just I like the I like the composition
of it I like the choreography of the
fight there's a certain peacefulness to
it while the chaos is going on it just I
remember thinking at the time
I don't think Stan Lee cameos were gonna
get any better than this but they did
they got one better so that brings us to
Stan Lee's cameo in spider-man into the
spider verse in this film he plays a
costume store owner and if you haven't
seen spider verse this is minor spoilers
you know for stuff that happens about a
half-hour in in the universe that Miles
Morales lives in spider-man that
universes version of spider-man Peter
Parker has died and everyone knows it
that's not a secret the world knows and
they have now learned that Peter Parker
was spider-man spider-man is dead and
miles trying to find some solace in what
has happened he goes to a costume store
then takes a bagged spider-man costume
and he puts it on the counter and
Stanley's behind the behind the register
and first of all like the movie came out
after Stan had passed
and he looks down at the masking he goes
I'm gonna miss him
we were friends you know and his passing
brought a real bitter sweetness to that
to that moment to that line but then
what happens after that is what really
elevates it because you have miles going
what if it doesn't fit meaning the
costume and Stan says well it always
fits eventually which works on multiple
levels because it he's actually speaking
to the themes of the film because the
film takes the idea that anyone can be
spider-man as its heart so this idea of
okay even if you're not the hero yet you
can be eventually this will fit but then
at the same time undercutting it because
the camera pans over to a sign that says
no returns or refunds ever which aside
from being a good joke I feel like is
also a bit of an acknowledgment of
Stan's nature as a showman and a little
bit of a huckster the guy cultivated his
own cult of personality he was one of
the very few names of a comic-book
writer who was a bigger name than
artists that just didn't happen and a
lot of the reason why that happened was
his cultivation of his own myth and
that's not to belittle his contributions
because the man has left an indelible
impact on on pop culture but there was a
certain amount of showmanship to that
persona and I feel like that final
moment is a little bit of a tip of the
hat and yet it's not so severe a tip
that it undermines the message of what
was said it's like just a little let's
let's keep the the reality in mind even
as this message was great and this man
is gonna be missed and maybe I'm reading
into that even more than was intended by
the filmmaker but I really did adore
that cameo and that's why it's my number
one pick for the best Stan Lee cameo
what are your thoughts what's your
favorite Stan Lee cameo in a movie any
movie Oh for the record mall rats that
doesn't count as a cameo that's that's
an extended supporting bit just putting
that out there but other than that
whatever you want to say drop something
down in the comments let's talk about a
whole bunch of stuff to do
buttons links patreon it helps other
links besides to check out p.o box all
that stuff give it a look at on the
description if you don't want to that is
okay because at the end of the day folks
you're the council I just run the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned true believers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]